[موسيقى]
نبدا باخر نتائج الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه وكاله استشيرت بريستا فادت
باحتفاظ الديمقراطيه بالاغلبيه البسيطه في
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي بعد فوز مرشحه الحزب
كاثرين كورتيز ماستو بمقعد المجلس يا
ولايه نيفادا في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
صوت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لهاريس
التي تتراسو مجلس الشيوخ مقابله 49
للجمهوريين
بارتفاع عدد مقاعد الديمقراطيين في مجلس
النواب الى 2004 مقابل 111 للجمهوريين حتى
اللحظه مع ترقب نتائج الانتخابات في ولايه
كاليفورنيا
وفي اول تعليق له بعد احتفاظه ديمقراطيين
بالاغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انه يشعر بسعاده بالغه
بنتائج الانتخابات النصفيه وهنا بايدينا
سيناتور تشاك شو مر لاحتفاظه بمنصب زعيم
الاغلبيه الديمقراطيه في مجلس
الشيوخاته
ان انتباهه منصب على نتيجه السباق للفوز
بمقعه ولايه جورجيا في مجلس الشيوخ حيث
ستجرى جوله ثانيه من الانتخابات بعد فشل
المرشحين الديمقراطيه والجمهوريه في تخطي
حاجز الخمسين بالمئه السياسيه
قبل القائه نظيره الصيني شو جنبيك خلال
قمه العشرين التي تستضيفها اندونيسيا
لم اتفاجا واشعر بفرحه غامره ان يكون لنا
51 مقعدا في مجلس الشيوخ امر محمود لانه
يخدمنا في اللجان بكل بساطه وانا واثق من
ان الديمقراطيين قادرون على الاحتفاظ
بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب
وعن الحزب الجمهوري اقتبس ما سمعته عندما
قال احدهم اين ترامب كشفها حقيقه تلك
التشكيله السياسيه
الصيني وقلم وقع سوء تفاهم بيننا ولا
طالما اجرته مباحثات صريحه ليس فيها سوء
تقدير البته